sin duda alguna cuando en 5 ó 10 años
los historiadores miren cuál es el
legado de angela merkel mirarán
exactamente esas crisis y cómo alemania
bajo el liderazgo de merkel incluso
salió fortalecido en algunas de esas
crisis estamos hablando desde una crisis
financiera hasta la crisis de los
refugiados pasando por la actual crisis
en temas de salud por el coronavirus
angela merkel sigue siendo una política
altamente popular en alemania de hecho
es la política con los niveles de
favorabilidad más altos del país
alrededor del 74 por ciento y eso 15
años después de haber asumido el poder
pero también cuando los historiadores
miren el legado de angela merkel mirarán
que ella deja un país cada vez más
polarizado que su política de llevar a
su partido hacia el centro del espectro
político dio cabida también para el
nacimiento y el desarrollo de la extrema
derecha del partido de extrema derecha
en alemania y es también en parte es un
legado que deja a angela merkel por
tanto entonces un legado con elementos
positivos el hecho de haber traído
estabilidad a alemania pero también el
hecho de que el país está
particularmente polarizado
bueno tomás y ahora lo que nos queda es
mirar hacia las próximas elecciones en
las que ella misma anunció ya hace
muchos meses de que no va a buscar
seguir liderando cómo se proyecta la
votación en el país
tal cual angela merkel no va a estar
presente en las próximas elecciones que
se prevén para septiembre del próximo
año y también es parte de su legado el
hecho de que su partido que si bien
estuvo en el poder durante 15 años hoy
también se pregunta exactamente cuál es
el rumbo que quiere seguir en los
próximos años si quieren seguir en ese
tipo centrista o si quieren moverse más
hacia la derecha y por eso es todavía
una pregunta abierta exactamente quién
va a liderar el partido de angela merkel
en las próximas elecciones y también
contra quién va a competir porque hasta
ahora de los grandes partidos alemanes
sólo uno los socialdemócratas ya
anunciaron cuál va a ser su candidato
así que todavía está completamente
abierto el panorama para las elecciones
que van a realizarse el próximo año aquí
en alemania